[Musique]
bonjour à tous ceux sur avait pour
trouver pour cette nouvelle émission
dans l'île de lecture avec une spéciale
bd aujourd'hui stéphanie bonjour bonjour
vous allez bien très bien vis très bien
je remercie aujourd'hui une nouvelle
invitée pauline amiens jour bonjour vous
êtes toutes les deux libraires à la
librairie le pavé du canal à
montigny-le-bretonneux
mais alors qui va commencer à nous
parler donc de bd suit donc au festival
d'angoulême tout à fait a eu lieu il ya
quinze jours à peu près à la fin en fait
c'était le dernier week-end de janvier
bon donc je crois qu'on commence avec
les coquelicots dira tout à fait l'écho
hier de l'irak de brigil voilà le voile
à l'école avec lui voient la fin d'un
cliché
honnêtement je ne sais pas effectivement
comment l'on dit et lewis trondheim nous
dresserons des mets un peu plus connu
effectivement en bande dessinée éditée à
l'association en fait elle raconte son
histoire son enfance son adolescence en
irak
elle est née à amazon les soupes
harbaoui mots soulevez et son père et
irakiens en entier c'est sa mère est
française
ils vivent effectivement un mot sol et
elle raconte voilà par petits souvenirs
quittant forcément dans l'ordre
chronologique mes souvenirs ce que
c'était une enfant ça me saoule 2050 a
jusqu'à
après les années 80 avec des allées
effectivement en france il avait la
chance de pouvoir partir en vacances à
mes france une grande famille donc ce
que c'est aussi d'avoir d'être un enfant
mix entre guillemets mer occidentale un
père au moyen-orient table parce que
c'est aussi cette loi là et puis toutes
les atteintes à les différences qui peut
y avoir aussi un pays à l'autre et aussi
les les incohérences qu'il peut y avoir
dans un pays qui en guerre depuis un
nombre d'années qui a connu
effectivement une dictature plusieurs
coups d'état manqués les raconte
successivement et effectivement les
absurdités qui monte petit à petit à
petit jusqu'à elle va famille va
finalement s'installer en france quant à
l'arrivée de saddam hussein voilà c'est
ça et tout à fait et elle continue à
passer les étés en irak et puis pour
finalement pu retrouver ses racines en
irak et me sens totalement et à la rive
qui du tout du tout à retrouver parce
qu'elle avait connue en dans son enfance
elle racontera peut être tendresse
oui beaucoup de situations absurdes de
fait difficile
tendresse il nous aussi parce qu'il ya
des petites pastilles c'est assez
cocasse ou originales de tradition par
exemple l'amant et française donc
beaucoup la cuisine je peux je suis lié
à la le fait surtout des bons gâteaux et
la tradition quand on termine un repas
et qu'on propose quand il en reste
encore la maîtrise de l'union propose
d'en inviter de reprendre encore une
part et la tradition veut que en général
par répondent non dont quand la
maîtresse de maison insiste ainsi
jusqu'à ce que l'invité dit ok est en
fait la maman tu habites usa donc elle
vous en voulez nono dans quel sens va
avec la moitié du gâteau
donc les gens sont pas du tout habitué à
ça donne bien sûr les différents et du
coup tout simplement l'or ces deux
petites voix la pastille un peu mystique
mais elle a d'autres un peu plus graves
auxquels elle dessine siècle et il s'est
trompé qu'il dessine la lettre en ce
sens et son compagnon
c'est un problème alors elle travaille
aussi en bande dessinée est les
coloristes en fait elle a colorié
différents albums et là ils s'associent
tous les deux donc c'est lui qui dessine
c'est elle qui raconte et c'est vraiment
un très bel album c'est je me nomme
d'accord oui puis un bel hommage aussi à
l'enfance est ce que l'on perd aussi de
l'enfance soline vous l'avez
également oui c'est un album qui évoque
un peu aussi persepolis marjane satrapi
c'est cette vision d'un conflit et d'un
pays en perdition de fabrice vial énorme
voilà donc c'est toujours assez tendre
et décalé au 10 parce que va pas
forcément ce qui se passerait bien sûr
c'est un bel album d'accord bon merci
beaucoup
témoin pauline on enchaîne avec le règne
la saison des démons alors c'est un
premier tome d'un cycle qui va en avoir
deux ces bois commun au dessin on
connaît pour meutre par exemple il fait
des dessins absolument extraordinaire
avec beaucoup de détails de perspectives
il travaille beaucoup sur les paysages
donc là on va suivre
on est dans notre monde donc l'humanité
n'existe prix voilà on la connaît enfin
l'humanité en tout cas les humains dans
ce premier tome n'existe pas ils ont
disparu donc c'est des animaux qui se
sont emparés de notre société
ils ont il ya différents niveaux sociaux
il ya des
des commerçants fin mais voilà il
reconnaît des singes tout à fait ça peut
ressembler à la planète des singes et on
va suivre une famille qui comme tous les
ans va se rendre un endroit très
particulier qui s'appelle le shrines et
le screen est gardée par des moines il
faut passer cet endroit parce que la
saison des démons arrive et cette saison
des démons c'est des catastrophes
naturelles d'accord donc cette famille
doit traverser une partie du pays et
rejoindre ce lieu un peu ça crée
évidemment sur la route ya des bandes
ils vont être protégé par un groupe de
trois mercenaires on voit sur la
couverture reliée par une guépard d'un
tigre blanc et 1
du fleuret un buffle donc voilà le ils
sont là pour protéger les plus offrants
il se trouve que c'est une famille très
riche donc ils se paient leurs services
et voilà on suit on suit ce petit groupe
dans toutes leurs péripéties et là la
saison des démons en fait c'est
ce que les hommes ont légué à la planète
c'est-à-dire des catastrophes naturelles
d'accord donc il ya un peu une
thématique aussi écologique de
conscience voilà d'accord voilà et c'est
épique s'éclater mad max animé moi mais
aussi tout à fait ou alors on voyait
déjà des convois de chariots un peu
fenomeno ma famille je n'ai pas lu moi
j'ai regardé pour le graphisme on sait
que parfois les personnages ressemblent
un peu à la série blacksad
oui aussi fraîche toutes les personnes
et j'aime beaucoup enfin j'aime bien
graphismes pas comme ça après l'histoire
justement j'ai pas lu mais le graphiste
la mer il et on a tendance à oublier que
c'est des animaux quoi le tigre est un
peu comme dans black salle est plutôt
sexy à 40,10 d'attraction très vite
alors on enchaîne pauline puisque vous y
êtes en garde avec la qui tua le québec
alors l'homme qui tuait lucky luke c'est
un hommage clairement à lucky luke
ouais c'est l'album qu'il faut dire si
on veut savoir pourquoi lucky luke à
arrêter les crimes et ils diraient pas
pourquoi on suit suis l'outil lucas
laure qui est connu dans le monde du
far-west entier qui peut pas rentrer
dans un bar sans qu'on lui demande de
dégainer plus vite que son nom
je voulais lui au début de l'album il
est en errance comme d'habitude et
qu'une envie c'est de trouver un bon lit
un beau repas il doit repartir le
lendemain matin
sauf que dans la ville où ils arrivent
déjà il ya plus de tabac donc ça pose
pas de problème a dit il est en plus un
convoi une diligence qui transportait de
l'or vient d'être attaqué par un indien
les shérifs locaux sont vraiment nuls
sont deux frères
le shérif officielle et un peu attardé
on comprend pourquoi après ses luthiers
chérif way est évidemment l'utilisent
qu'il va être chargé de s'occuper de ça
sauf que ça ne va pas se passer comme
prévu
c'était quoi une histoire d'amour un peu
pour le ter pour de l'auteur pour
l'équipe ça fait envie de rendre un
hommage mais c'est clairement un hommage
et il reprend tous les codes de lucky
luke mais il est je le trouve beaucoup
plus humain et psychologiquement plus
fin que dans les lucky luke de maurice
dakar là où c'était un petit peu plus
mais là ils droit alors je me demandais
un peu oui tout à fait il y en a plein
de youtube qui sorte qu'ils sont des
hommages en fait comme stéphanie va
parler de cause et karine duo belge à
mickey
j'imagine que c'est très compliqué à ma
démarche
j'avais pris tier je mange tous d'accord
ça donne en tout cas j'aimerais bien
savoir pourquoi il a fait ça on pourrait
en motiver quelques-uns des fans merci
buffo pauline alors cet hommage à cause
est connue la nuit qui a eu le grand
prix du jury d'angoulême je le rappelle
récompense pas un album mais une oeuvre
tout à fait voilà ce qui est un peu la
consécration à la autre vie mais est en
plus celui effectivement qui est
réprimée il a la gale joueurs d'être le
président de la session prochaine car
c'est lui qui sera président du festival
l'année d'après en 2018 et causait c'est
un auteur de bande dessinée suisse
sandro et qui est né dans les années 50
et qui est surtout connu pour la bande
dessinée pour la série johnathan
d'accord alors cause s et on part en
voyage avec osé comparer à l'aventuré on
part en voyage alors notamment
effectivement avec la série de nathan
qui est un jeune homme d'origine suisse
qui part sur les cimes himalayenne pour
à la recherche d'un amour perdu
et c'est vrai que la majorité de ses
albums c'est surtout l'amour qui est le
premier moteur entre guillemets le fait
d'acteurs il est initié la série
complètement c'est la fin de toute
intérieure une quête insight
et puis son dessin là on le voit sur la
couverture
quand on parle beaucoup pas seulement
parce que c'est la montagne je trouve
son essence
il ya beaucoup de douceur vous le livre
sur les amoureux de la montagne
il a fondé sain et très il ya beaucoup
de douceur et danse à de bonnes
nouvelles après un contemplatif
oui mais c'est pas nombriliste entre
guillemets mais c'est pas non plus oui
voilà il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'humanité
je trouve dans son discours il prend
souvent fait et cause pour les pour des
petites des petits et oui des petites
gens là alors surtout chez jonathan il
prend beaucoup fait et cause pour la
cause tibétaine
la présence chinoise sur notre organisme
j'ai tout à fait c'est presque de l'auto
fiction les débuts jonathan parce que
son héros il ressemble beaucoup
vraiment quand on voit 30 ans la tête de
cosey c'est vraiment la tête de
l'attentât qui lui même beaucoup
précédente
voilà tout à fait il apparaît que ça
après coup qu'il ya eu d'autres
effectivement il faut voyager aux états
unis
un voyage aussi long a fait beaucoup
même en asie du sud est sont birmane et
en relais hausse en asie la hausse voit
là son dernier album qui est tout à fait
qui est un hommage en voilà un disque
live figure tout à fait et là encore
c'est aussi l'amour qui voilà qui est le
début en tout cas la quête du roman pas
d'hier m'ont dit vous avez des tas car
et c'est effectivement à la fois leurs
douze ça fait un parapet taponier on
voit quelques images un derrière ni à
dire ça mais il ya quelque chose de très
profond
effectivement et il nous est une
adorable et je trouve
voilà on a découvert tout à fait
d'accord oui moi soit ravi qu'il ait
bien fait c'est ça il n'est pas
forcément très connu de très grand
public oui et ça va effectivement lui
donner un autre regard et l'insolence je
crois savoir que vous voulez aussi
rendre un hommage tout à fait un auteur
disparu a très récemment
là on en avait parlé à la première
émission qui est décédé le
11 février et effectivement dans
l'émission de la première émission
c'était quoi lieu en 2017 j'avais
proposé d'amener gauche et donc oui
lisait encore plus tard niveau sinon il
va beaucoup nous manquer enfin moi je
trouve pas ce que grand pardon également
beaucoup de poésie beaucoup du manoir
est aussi un très très beau dessin tout
le monde peut le lire c'est parce que
c'est du manga que c'est au contraire
c'est ouvert à beaucoup beaucoup de gens
ya aussi beaucoup de sensibilité ce
serait un terrain très content auteurs
mais voilà c'est moi je vous remercie
sous les 2 c pour tous ces conseils et
puis on a des bd à lire donc à très
bientôt
à bientôt merci merci
[Musique]